do you have advice in general for people
you're already exceptionally successful
you're young but you have advice for
young people
starting out in college or maybe in high
school you know
advice for their career advice for their
life how to
pave a successful path and career in
life
i would say just be hungry uh like
always be hungry for what you want
and i think like i've been inspired by a
lot of people who are just like driven
and who really like go for what they
want no matter what
like you shouldn't want it you should
need it so if you need something you
basically go
towards the ends to make it work how do
you know when you you come across a
thing
that that's like you need
i think there's not going to be any
single thing that you're going to need
there are going to be different types of
things that you need but
whenever you need something you just go
push for it and of course once you
you may not get it or you may find that
this was not even the thing that you
were looking for it might be a different
thing but the point is
like you're pushing through things and
that actually gives you
brings a lot of skills and brings a lot
of like
build a certain kind of attitude which
will probably help you get the other
thing
once you figure out what's really the
thing that you want yeah i think a lot
of people
are i've noticed the kind of afraid of
that
is because one is the fear of commitment
and two there's so many amazing things
in this world you almost don't want to
miss out on all the other amazing things
by committing to this one thing
so i think a lot of it has to do with
just allowing yourself to uh
like notice that thing and uh
just go all the way with it i mean i
also like failure right
so yeah i know this is like super cheesy
that you know failure is something that
you should be prepared for and so on but
i do think i mean especially in research
for example failure is something that
happens almost like
almost every day is like experiments
failing and not working
and so you really need to be so used to
it you need to have a thick skin
but and only basically through like when
you get through it is when you find the
one thing that's actually working
like thomas edison was like one person
like that right so i really
like when i was a kid i used to really
read about how he uh found like the
filament and the light bulb filament
and then he i think his thing was like
he tried 990 things that didn't work or
something of the sort yeah and then they
asked him like so what did you learn
because all of these were failed
experiments and then he says oh these
990 things
don't work and i know that did you know
that
yeah that's pretty inspiring
you